hi Erica how are you today I'm good
thanks for coming back I'm glad to be
back on yeah glad we got you back on for
those of you weren't listening another
hour she got kicked off the air
accidentally technical difficulties so
how can I help today
all right it was like a what would Dave
do type of situation I my mother-in-law
she is completely dependent on Social
Security I think it's around $500 a
month and my husband has been out of
work for about a year he just started
working recently about a month ago and
we've been having to foot the bill for
her living expenses
how are you putting the bill for her
living expenses if he's not had work in
a year well I work I make about 20 a
little under twenty four thousand a year
we were living with her for about nine
months and it was just too much for me
to commute living with her and then
going to where I work so basically I've
we've I've been the one that's been
putting her now basically and she does
not see eye to eye with our principles
she has a lot of credit card debt I'm
not sure how much you said your husband
you said your husband is now working he
is it's been about a month and what is
your household income now I don't know
adding that on because he does he's got
a seasonal job so I didn't really do the
math for that but last month he brought
in around $2,000 okay that's about
24,000 a year there so you got your
household income up to around 50 or so
give or take 45 or 50 and she's living
on a social security check but is still
asking for help from you and she's
spending money on credit cards she is
spending money on art supplies she
pays for it with her credit cards she
has a second mortgage on the house and
whether she do with the art supplies um
I've want to say that she hoards them
but if you ask her she is using them but
does she does she sell art no okay all
right so I'm guessing that your husband
is not very assertive with his mother
he's tried I mean we I try not to be
there for the conversations that they
have but it always ends up the same she
keeps saying that whatever money we give
her is a loan which doesn't make me feel
better I mean I it's not alone I'm not
giving you any more money okay and you
and your husband need to sit down and
here's a rule that you need to have this
is a this is a rule of wise people do
not to give money to people who will not
take your advice right and your husband
needs to say mom the only way we're
going to continue to pour money into
this situation is you're going to follow
our financial advice if you don't want
to follow that that's fine but we will
not be giving you any more right and
that's that's kind of how I'm thinking
you know because we've been we were on
the debt snowball and we were down to
about $3,000 left and it's just been
really hard because I feel like let's
pretend let's pretend you had a million
dollars in the bank mm-hmm you still
don't give money to someone who's
misbehaving great I do not give money to
people who will not take my financial
advice because I have an obligation to
God to manage God's money for God's
glory and when I participate in
someone's misbehavior I'm not only
endorsing it I'm financing it with God's
money that does not make God smile it's
not helping his mother - it's not for
your husband to allow her to continue to
hurt herself financially
she's harming herself financially with
her bad decisions and when you give her
money to do that you're like saying hey
mom I hate you so much that I would like
you Haiti hurting yourself and that's
basically what you're doing and you got
to stop it
and I I don't know I think the just the
promise I mean if we've also talked to
her about writing a will you know I
don't care about her will I don't even
care about her stuff she can give it all
to charity I care about her being a
whole person making good decisions for
her sake to have some dignity right now
she's just a drunk that needs another
drink that's all she is she's just
another drunk that needs another drink
and it's sad it's pitiful and I care
about her breaking away from this
horrible lack of self discipline this
horrible break from reality that says
that money just comes you know it just
shows up just because I want some and
and that's not good for her it's not
good for her at all and so the the
whether she's gonna give you the money
back is not in question I'm not trying
to make money or lose money in this
scenario I'm trying to help his mother
and the way she gets helped is not
participating in her crazy that's why I
don't give financial advice or why I
don't give money to people who won't
take my financial advice by the way it's
the same thing with our Family
Foundation we do not give money to
ministries who run you know who run
their ministry with a different
philosophy than we believed to be wisdom
and we're not controlling we just don't
think it's wise for us to give money to
something someone that's doing something
that we wouldn't do and so we're not
gonna do that we're not gonna
participate in that hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my
my own youtube channel yes that's right
it's kind of better than the dayroom 2
channel I'll tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget
one of the best videos out there
you